hey everybody I'm so glad you're joining
me today because this is going to be the
last stream for a few days because we're
going on vacation starting start really
when we're done with all of today's
stuff we are on vacation until Monday
and it is not the last stream ever but
it is the last stream for a little bit I
have a bunch of different stuff that I
want to show you today let me make sure
I have everything pulled up here we are
standing by for Donald Trump giving a
press conference it's going to be
alongside the President of Poland and I
have a little bit of video from their
oval office meeting just a little while
ago and it was pretty damn chaotic we're
gonna look at that in a little bit but
right now we're standing by for Trump
scheduled for the bottom of the hour and
we will see whether that happens or what
time you know if and when it's always a
question mark with Trump I am glad that
so many of you joined me yesterday for
Donald Trump's Corona rally in a church
in Phoenix Arizona
or was it Phoenix it was in Arizona and
so many questions about it I thought
churches were supposed to be
non-political but they're hosting a
Trump campaign event that doesn't seem
right does it make sense to have 3,000
people in a room with no masks when
coronavirus is exploding in Arizona the
answer is of course it doesn't so a lot
of different things including Trump
again not only Trump mentioning kung flu
but the crowd demanding Kong flu so
we're gonna get to all of that
momentarily welcome if you're watching
on Twitter twitch YouTube or Facebook I
have a little bit of David Pakman show
trivia for you today yesterday June 23
2020 we simultaneously had on the same
day the most audio podcast downloads
ever in the history of the David Pakman
show and the most facebook video views
ever in the history of the David Pakman
show both of those milestones happened
yesterday which is incredible as Donald
Trump would say it was it was a real gig
moment as some of you would say I want
to say thanks to Deborah spinner because
she just grabbed a membership on my
website and she's new member number one
today I see a few questions or comments
coming in via super chat and then we're
gonna get to some videos incredible TV
says yo just got my wife into your show
during Trump's hate rally yesterday
thanks for the great work David she'll
be a member in no time yes also mr.
winklebottom says have a great vacation
hope you have a good time thank you I am
looking forward to it so let's look at a
couple of different things here is the
meeting Trump had just minutes ago with
the a president from Poland and you'll
see here we go
[Music]
they could really get a better mic on
this guy it's like between the shutter
and being off mic this is not great
audio it instantly gets extremely K this
is like ever I mean everybody I mean
they're trying to kick people it's crazy
what's going on why did you decide now
is a good time to have the first foreign
leader since all the shut down you can
hear everything but at the actual people
you're supposed to hear
so thank you and do you think this is a
mark of progress in the coronavirus this
entire thing is only three minutes and
as you can see it's just a little bit of
talking and then there's this amount of
screaming I mean it's as if there's
always screaming surrounding Trump chaos
surrounding turd there's a helicopter
going or people they're yelling right in
front of the K it's always chaos so I
think we're done with that let me just
see what's going on over here okay
they're not starting yet so then
yesterday at Trump's rally in in Arizona
not only does Trump again refer to the
coronavirus as the come flu but the
crowd is actually demanding it and I
think that the crib the critique here is
really as much about the people that
like this stuff as it is about Trump
because Trump's just one guy if nobody
if calling this the come flu didn't
resonate with anybody Trump would have
no shot right like the reason Trump's
president is stuff like calling this the
come flu actually resonates with roomful
of people you'll hear the crowd chanting
Kong flu before Trump even mentions it
chunk California off the record
California would say please can we have
the world this is California note they
didn't want the world they don't want
the wall but they wanted the wall right
because right next to San Diego's a
wonderful town in Mexico you know the
town I won't mention the name but
they're heavily infected with Cove aide
David notice I said the other night did
anybody see my speech the other night on
Saturday there
what I said the other night there's
never been anything where they have so
many names I could give you 19 or 20
names for that right it's got all
different names Wuhan kau Hans who
somehow people start shouting come flu
they want him to say it Cheon
coronavirus right Kong flu I'm not here
in ten years sitting around I said this
on our podcast today which by the way
you should be subscribed to imagine in
10 years hey remember that time we went
to that Trump rally and he said come flu
yeah that was just so great I was just
so fired up when he said come flu so the
fact that there's a roomful of people
willing to cheer for that is a really
big part of the problem that it's we
should be as embarrassed by that as as
we are by the fact that we have a
president who says this stuff we also
have a room full of people who cheers
when Trump remember right they cheer
that Trump drank water they cheer that
Trump says come flu that's a huge part
of the problem it's the people and
obviously you know that because more
than 660 ish million people voted for
this guy and we we the problem but the
problem is deeper than just Trump I
think that that's very very clear at
this point
Chad Lightning says thoughts on how to
combat people saying if you don't
subscribe to narratives like all cops
are bastards and others mixed in with
black lives matter you're not for black
lives matter
I wouldn't even engage with people like
that those are just bad faith arguments
and I don't any any arguments based on
labels and etc I I think are just III
personally try to avoid engaging in that
it's just a waste of time thanks to fje
for subscribing and also Ron says can
there be an alliance between the left
and populist right I think this notion
only validates ideologies from Tucker
Carlson and his ilk check out my video
on this issue hold on a second let me
see Pakman populism social democracy
yeah so check out this video that I did
a little while ago not that long ago it
is called social democracy is being
destroyed by quote populism it's about a
month and a half old when I do these the
they never get a lot of views but I feel
like they're important videos to do I
address this issue in detail in that
video clip so I encourage you to check
that out and Jake says can we all drink
water 2-handed in solidarity with you
yeah please do I posted this by the way
yester this morning this somebody zoomed
this in this is from yesterday's stream
this was me drinking water during
yesterday's stream and as you can see
I'm also using this technique yep there
it is so that sounded mighty yeah this
is real life this is on my Twitter
account D Pakman and as you can see
there I didn't pucker my lips as much as
maybe other people do when they do this
stress I feel like I'm exerting if it
weren't for the fact that I was born in
Argentina this is very very presidential
material right here okay
so there's that thank you I want to say
thank you very quickly to Vladimir SARP
who has just subscribed on my website at
join pakman.com
very much appreciated and a huge thank
you do you guys have any idea what's
going on on Twitch right now there is a
hype train there's so many things
happening Clayton B has subscribed with
prime ask the alligator has subscribed
with with prime fat Clemenza has
subscribed with prime and United
Airlines 13:37 has also subscribed with
prime and it's all it's all happening
there Syed Ahmad says appreciate your
commentary during these rallies and such
it makes watching these train wrecks
worth it thank you I very much
appreciate that seth Barham says hey
David how can we convince right-wingers
that the media isn't a monolith and
there are reliable sources outside of
their bubble like Reuters and The
Associated Press I don't know I don't
even know that that's something I'd be
talking about too much with
right-wingers it just quite frankly it
seems like a waste of time let's just
let's focus on removing Trump then we'll
talk to right-wingers about the media
you know I don't know that I'd weigh
my time with that right now thanks the
deeper shades of house ruski and quartic
all of whom have just subscribed over on
Twitch if you're wondering where those
messages are coming from on the lower
left of your screen
they are YouTube super chats which are
the dollar sign at the bottom of the
chat window or if you're on mobile
I think it's an overlay on mobile mobile
I am an Android guy so I don't know if
it's different on Android than it is on
on an iPhone but in any case that's a
it's all happening and it's all
extremely exciting as we wait for Donald
Trump at the bottom of the hour I'm
hopeful that Donald Trump will be asked
questions about coronavirus and hopeful
he'll be asked questions about kung flu
I'm hopeful he'll be asked questions
about testing and Michael Flynn and I
mean there's just so much and and some
of the questions may be what he would
characterize as nasty and that would
only make it better I hope that that
happens let me do a little bit on
coronavirus okay there's something very
very there's a talking point that we
need to dispel as you can see
increasingly the states with the most
cases they're mostly red states right
like Texas Arizona Florida Georgia
Louisiana South Carolina North Carolina
Tennessee okay New York was an early hot
spot Alabama Pennsylvania was early
Mississippi California is often pointed
to by Republicans as an example of a
blue state that's doing terribly and
indeed California is having a lot of new
cases but you know how the right loves
to say Texas only has more cases because
they're testing so much Florida or
Florida only have more cases because
they're testing so much it's not true
with any of those states it does seem to
be true with California so let me let me
actually show you the data
here's California you can see yellow is
the number of tests the number of tests
has been going up up up up up up up up
to nearly a hundred thousand tests a day
up from only 20,000 the blue line is the
positive test rate it's barely going up
in the
few days it's gone up a little bit but
California has tested more and more but
their tests the positive rate has
remained between four and a half and
five and a half percent this is actual
evidence that a lot of California's
numbers are because they are testing
more not because the infection rate is
getting worse
let's compare now okay if you look
instead at Texas Texas has been testing
more sporadically it's sort of up and
down but their positive test rate was
around four and a half five percent in
late May it's now regularly as high as
10 or 11 percent so when the Republicans
say there's no David there's no problem
in Texas
we're just texting so much right they
love to say that their positive test
rate has doubled in Arizona look at this
the positive test rate in Arizona has
gone from about six and a half percent
all the way up to 22 percent so
California same positive test rate Texas
doubled Arizona quadrupled positive test
rate let's just do one more example
Florida I mean look at this the positive
test rate in Florida has gone from 2% to
13% up more than 6x so please be aware
of this website this is the Johns
Hopkins University of Medicine
coronavirus Resource Center when they
say it's disastrous in California
California's positive test rate is very
very steady how is Massachusetts doing
by the way I know we're doing pretty
well beautiful look at that that's a
that's what we call a perfect curve
Trump tried to have a perfect phone call
failed this is what I would call a
beautiful curve and I absolutely love it
so in any case
yeah listen that that's a it's a widely
repeated but inaccurate very very
inaccurate talking point we shouldn't
fall for it ever ever ever ever we care
about the data we care about the data
and not about lies that we hear from
Donald Trump so very very
let me see what else I had here I think
we've gone through most of what I wanted
to touch on before this starts yeah I
think so okay let me look at a few of
the super chats that are coming in oh
sorry no CAHSEE has subscribed on Twitch
for three months in a row oh and that's
it okay all right nothing else going on
there over on YouTube a lot of questions
coming in let's see
Deborah Pierce has subscribed Marta
Brewer says polish presidential
elections coming up on Sunday Duda is
playing a dangerous game talking about
LGBT ideology being worse than communism
scary stuff yeah I don't I I you know I
try not to comment on things I don't
really know much about and I've not been
following much of Polish politics so
it's probably not you know I leave it to
the experts to comment on that
breaker 19 says David the argument on
testing is a non-starter just ask why
hospitalizations are going up are these
people faking sick yeah hospitalization
is also a good metric to look at and
yeah I completely agree full stop thanks
to a cross and kale Khan both of whom
just subscribed over on Twitch which I
very much appreciate somebody is saying
that I sent them a cameo of me taking my
shirt off that is not true the cameos
are rolling in I actually had a couple
funny ones a lot of people are at this
is actually pretty funny a lot of people
are asking me to do like inspirational
sort of messages for people and I'm not
really an inspirational speaker so like
let's look at one from today this could
be cringed let's just take a look but I
love that people are asking me to do
stuff let's listen hey Robby just want
to say congratulations on graduating
high school recently you're going
the J mu J mu is great I have a few
friends that went there and had
absolutely fantastic experiences College
is really what you make of it it can be
okay or it can be great depending on
what can you imagine a more
inspirational speech than this imagine
getting this K I hope this isn't a
downer to the person that receives us do
make of it I think that's really
important to keep in mind also you know
a lot of people right now that are
feeling disappointed because of
everything that's going on this doesn't
feel like the best time to be graduating
high school right we're starting college
or whatever the case may be I'm gonna
build them ups going to be different
it's going to be different and in the
short run it might not feel as good but
I actually think that people who
navigate this is going to be tougher
right graduating high school and going
to college now Army Reserves all of this
stuff it's gonna be tougher now than it
normally would be I think it'll just
make people more resilient and anti
fragile so I think in the long run it's
gonna actually serve you really really
well and you know right now there's
something very easy even though things
may not be great in a lot of ways just
wearing a mask any opportunity to wear a
mask is something so small because
Robby's dad said also please mention the
importance of wearing a mask I think
Robbie and his dad are maybe had a disk
at an impasse when it comes to this from
the standpoint of masks they may be at
an impasse so anyway I'm having fun
doing these I got about 20 requests and
I've done all of them something I'm
doing I'm usually within the hour
because they just pop up on my phone but
yeah cameo got in touch with me last
week and they said we've been getting
requests for you can you imagine people
write to cameo and they say we really
need David Pakman on on your platform
but cameo got in touch with me and I'm
on there and we're having a great grand
old time so that's something something
to think about let me say thank you to
Martin Horace Co who is new member
number three today at join pakman.com
very much appreciate that thank you so
much for the support okay
other super chats coming in insane Lane
says have you been able to watch the
fireworks in the DOJ hearing today ie
the banging I know I don't know I've
been so busy with today's show today
that I have not
I've not seen that but it sounds wild it
certainly sounds very very crazy thanks
also to Johan de guru for the Prime
subscription Eddie G has subscribed with
prime future lane and bear was dead are
also now supporting on Twitch which is
very very exciting as we stand by for a
press conference with Donald Trump as
well as the Polish president I pronounce
it andrzej duda I don't know if it's
actually Andrej that there's there's an
in there which I'm not exactly sure
whether it's silent or what the deal is
but I find it most reasonable to say
Andre and I don't know if that's
accurate or or not accurate but be that
as it is what's going on here let's say
it's a Mic Check okay very good
beautiful perfect microphone really
really great this is good it's just
gonna be a great we're expecting nasty
questions for sure let me mention very
very briefly I didn't even I think a lot
of you will be very proud I've been told
David if you restrict the membership
promos you may actually get more people
signing up during yesterday's entire
rally with with Trump I didn't do a
single membership promo and it was
beautiful and so today I'm only going to
do one mostly were supported by
memberships on my website join
pakman.com consider this a personal
invitation go to join pakman.com grab a
membership I will thank every last one
of you three folks have signed up we
have a modest goal I believe it's modest
of 25 it's a perfect goal really and you
can if you want use the coupon code in
blue text above my head 2020 now that'll
chop 20 I'm sorry 66% off of the price
of a membership don't feel obligated but
it's available to you it's not
means-tested everybody do whatever is
best for them the show is for everybody
we do the podcast
for free we do the YouTube clips this we
do everything for free we estimate about
0.5% of our audience has memberships if
we could get that to 1% it would be a
historic game-changer a historic
game-changer so consider yourselves
invited and I'll thank everybody
everybody who signs up during the stream
a javi Rodriguez says this Trump have
any chance of winning the popular vote
yeah he has a chance he has a chance but
we've got to prevent him from doing it
oh I missed a couple of these pear
tieran from Sweden says have a beautiful
breather to recharge the batteries eat
good relax and reflect but what will
happen to the strawberry plant yeah so
during my vacation I am making
arrangements to have my vegetable garden
tended to and watered and it's gonna be
I think it's gonna be fine Jake says do
you know why the Oh a and reporter
doesn't get a seat with the other
reporters I thought the yoga ball theory
you had was hilarious yeah I I don't
exactly know the full backstory on why
the oen reporter is not allowed a seat
anymore I think it has to do with the
White House Correspondents Association
but I hypothesized last week or earlier
this week I don't know when it was that
maybe she would start bringing a blow-up
ball like a yoga ball and sit on that
what else do we have
Alexander the Snivy says I'm worried
that a side effect of the Democrats
retaking the White House will be but
that the media will be extra lakhs on
Biden or his vice president's
administration I don't expect that and
to be perfectly frank the analogy I've
used is if you imagine a football game
for the last three and a half years the
other team has had the ball so we're
playing defense when we get the ball
that's not the end of the game if we get
the ball meaning Biden gets elected
that's when the game starts that's when
we go on offense and that's the analogy
I mean listen I'll do everything I can
to get Trump removed in November and if
Biden is inaugurated in January that's
when we now say let's push this guy to
be as progressive as possible under
Trump we're trying to stop bad things
from happening with Biden that's when
the game starts that is the it's the
whole game you get you can only score
well I mean listen I guess you can
intercept the ball and then get a
touchdown okay so you can sort of score
on defense I think you understand
there's also a safety but we're getting
very very into the weeds here the
analogy is we start our game plan once
we get the ball back
and that's my perspective so to speak if
you're just joining me on youtube
remember to like the stream and
subscribe to my youtube channel we are
on track I hesitate to say this but I
think it's a pretty safe thing to say
June may be the best month we would have
on YouTube from the standpoint of
subscribers in a really really really
long time we're up to eight hundred and
sixty five thousand on YouTube which is
unbelievable
we're approaching forty thousand
followers on Twitch which is just
extraordinary and it's just I really
appreciate everybody who's been who's
been supporting oh hold on a second is
there anti-semitism that we have to
block we may have okay yeah yeah oh the
anti-semitism is starting okay
moderators please the the anti-semitism
is an insta ban okay don't worry about
it you're deputized to do the insta ban
on anti-semitism Ben Williams says my
girlfriend told me she thinks she might
be pregnant
thank God I stole the pregnancy test
from her purse I could never afford a
kid right now yeah if you don't test for
a baby
there's no baby I mean you can
dramatically reduce the number of babies
by dramatically reducing the number of
pregnancy tests everybody knows that
that's the way it works right I'm
kidding by the way obviously that's an
analogy to Trump's coronavirus testing
idea
slow it down then we won't have tests
okay Daniel v'lo toover says how can we
get money out of Elections the
fundraising quotas for the debates the
fact that Bloomberg bought his way into
the election is gross I've got a lot of
clips on campaign finance reform and
that is a big big story it's it's a huge
that we could we should do an hour on
that and I don't want a divert now
because we
no doubt get interrupted Daniel Baniya
says is never Biden a Russia try to
discourage the den vote I don't need I
don't care in the sense that it's a bad
idea and I don't care where it came from
I'm not gonna be supportive of it period
I don't really know how else to how else
to say it okay we have oh let me see
here
somebody said they had a problem on my
website grabbing a membership we've
quadrupled the resources on the website
it should be working fine see here yeah
every it seems to be working fine it
might just be user error but everything
does seem to be working absolutely
beautifully on the website dak dak says
analysis of the bar testimony highlights
I'm putting something together I'll have
something for you
Jamal Swift says hey homie is this all
real it is unfortunately all too real
Jamal
sadly breaker 19 says what happens if
Biden dies between November and January
what happens what I mean no let's say
I'm not even gonna get into that right
now
incredible TV says your daily reminder
that school choice is the civil rights
issue of our time yeah that's the new
thing from from Donald Trump now
interjecting school choice in the midst
of police protests against police
brutality Trump interjecting that really
the civil rights issue of our time is
school choice which is code for take
money from public schools and give it to
private schools which makes public
schools function even worse because
you're defunding them which justifies
taking even more money away from public
schools it's it's a vicious cycle that
they just love let's see here Roe likho
has just subscribed with twitch prime
off skip has just subscribed with prime
in 88 fingers says where is vacation I
am vacationing within the state of
Massachusetts because I believe that's
the safest thing to do I don't want to
say exactly where but a beautiful
beautiful place and I will be I will be
on the beach I will be grilling I will
be
I'm gonna be doing so many amazing
things it's gonna be crazy also thanks
to I'm inconsolable for gifting a
subscription I'm inconsolable has now
gifted 358 358 subscriptions is I'm
inconsolable the same as turkey bacon
now I'm wondering if turkey bacon
changed their username and as I'm
inconsolable huh because I thought
turkey bacon had the most gifted
subscriptions that's interesting we're
gonna have to look at that
Daniel testify Tess Fey says his Michael
Flynn above the law
in a sense in a sense I mean it's like
he said he did the thing and they're
like yeah we don't really want to
prosecute Charlie says a shame okay I'm
sorry I don't know what that means Erik
says I bet you won't spend your holiday
in Europe no Americans are gonna be
banned from traveling to Europe and you
know the u.s. is such a huge country
that if it were possible to block people
from certain states to go if from going
to certain other states like
Massachusetts is thinking of would it be
possible to prevent Floridians from
coming here if you could do that you
could justify saying well Massachusetts
is doing great you should be able to fly
from message from Boston to Paris for
example but because ingress and egress
from in two states is constitutionally
enshrined and very difficult to stop the
entire country everybody from the US is
just gonna be blocked from traveling to
Europe so there go there go my summer
plans that's true a thanks to lame EG
for subscribing with twitch prime I
appreciate that
let's see bad that's say oh there's Mike
Pompeo oh god he's horrible oh my god
he's disgusting bat says shout out to
the dgg watchers Ave Caesar says when
are you and Michael Brooks going to team
up you demand David I don't know that
could be something to look at we've got
uh just a whole bunch of horrible
horrible Trump people coming out I want
to say thank you to Sheila Wyatt who is
new member number four today
pakman.com very much appreciate Sheila
Wyatt subscribing I want to say thank
you to Chris Arnold who is new member
number 5 at join pakman.com and andreas
Bosch who is new member number 6 today
Wow 6 at join pakman.com very very much
appreciated as it looks like we're
getting pretty close to the start of
this press conference with Donald Trump
and the Polish President Andrzej Duda
hoping that Donald Trump is asked a
number of nasty questions Luke says
don't forget to smash the like button
hiding behind the live chat folks this
man is out here working hard for us
thank you I'm inconsolable says turkey
bacon and cheese is I'm inconsolable
decided to go with something more
vegetarian friendly I love it
all right here we go let's see what's
going on and I want to thank everybody
for being here with us we all know what
a wonderful country in a great country
Poland is and it's my honor to have a
friend of mine here president Duda of
Poland who has done an incredible job
and I do believe he has an election
coming up and I do believe he'll be very
successful ok so thank you very much and
all of your representatives thank you
very much for being here this is the
third time that we've hosted president
Duda the first lady and I also cherish
your remarkable visit to Poland three
years ago that was an amazing event
Trump has now had an event because it
was a speech and a lot of people watched
that speech but it was a very historic
he got grill marks and an important
moment for our two countries the
American a Polish people enjoy one of
the world's oldest strongest and most
enduring friendships thanks Holly by the
polish Patriots battled by our side to
secure American independence American
and Polish warriors fought and died
together to defeat the Nazis in World
War two the United States stood
shoulder-to-shoulder
with Poland and it's courageous struggle
against communist oppression our bond
has been forged in battle sealed in
blood and strengthened by our shared
cultural values you can tell you really
the United States and Poland are united
by our firm conviction that Western
civilization is advanced really in very
much advanced I think I have to add the
cause of human progress beyond measure
and that it must be strongly defended
and will at all times be strongly
defended and we will defend it together
in our meeting today president Duda and
I reaffirmed the vital alliance between
our nation's last year we signed two
joint declarations to increase our
security collaboration and we look
forward to signing a defense cooperation
agreement poland recently perches 32
brand new state-of-the-art f-35 fighter
jets the best in the world military is
one of only eight NATO members the
others some of them haven't done so well
in terms of what they're supposed to be
paying to NATO I tell them all the time
and we've gotten him up a lot but not
enough but Poland is one of only eight
that is current with the money that they
are supposed to be paying that's the two
percent two percent is a very low number
but we have a large number of countries
that haven't paid their delinquent let's
put it that way they're delinquent with
respect to their dues the money they're
supposed to be paying for defense so the
United States is defending a lot of
countries they're delinquent on what
they're supposed to be paying and I
never feel too good about that but I
will say I spoke with the
secretary-general and he said we've done
a great job but I said we haven't done
good enough we haven't done a good
enough job we have secured though over
four hundred billion dollars in new
pledge defense spending from NATO
members which is something that no other
administration has come even close to I
would say they're off by many many
hundreds of billions of dollars
something the newspaper doesn't like
writing about
that the media doesn't like talking
about but we will be only satisfied when
all members are paying their fair share
again only eight members plus the United
States is paying what is considered a
fair share part I also applaud Poland
and the Polish people force devotion to
safeguarding their country's borders
very strong borders and I just left our
border by the way the wall is moving
along rapidly and our border is about as
strong as it's ever been
our southern border last year we were
able to add Paul wrong it's ever been
and yet we're supposed to believe the
virus is coming into southern states
from Mexico mmm how how could both be
true if it it's a testament to Poland's
vigilant efforts to uphold the rule of
law the United States and Poland have
recently signed several long-term
contracts for us liquefied natural gas
they're a big purchase of of our energy
to enhance Poland's
energy security and we're working to
conclude an agreement that would
facilitates facilitate Poland's
development of nuclear energy plants
throughout the purchase they were going
to be purchasing with one of our very
big very good companies technology to do
civilian nuclear energy I want to
congratulate Poland for its leadership
in the three seas initiative a crucial
energy partnership that will provide a
reliable source of energy for Eastern
Europe and it will be free from the
threat of foreign extortion Poland
understands foreign extortion very well
the 30 season I should have realized our
fairness transparency and mutual benefit
our nations have also collaborated on
protecting our critical infrastructure
and technology
that's why we've signed a five GE joint
declaration and Poland is leading the
way in Europe by using trusted providers
and provider equipment and supply chains
for its 5g network and we're working
along with them and they're using our
companies the United States and Poland
cooperate across the truly wide range of
fronts that were
very much involved in here today is the
head of a Polish medical team very
advanced team very brilliant team
fighting Pantheon coronavirus alongside
of American doctors captain che Veera
captain thank you very much for being
here captain save a rock and we're
making great progress I hear we're
making great progress and we're working
together but we are making great
progress on therapeutics and vaccines
there's no idea what he's really being
here the American a Polish people have
been a true friends and trusted partners
for almost 250 years right we're forever
united by our shared belief and family
faith law liberty democracy and justice
as the old polish motto goes we will
stand together in the name of God for
our freedom and for yours can you
imagine to do - let me express once
again our gratitude for your visit and
friendship we have had a very very
special relationship our alliance is
powerful and a very powerful testament
to what free people can achieve together
very strong and I believe that the
greatness of our relationship lies ahead
thank you very much president boss thank
you thank you very much mr. president
do you buy oh my god we can barely hear
a word of this President Trump to the
President of the United States of
America thank you very much for inviting
me here to Washington to the White House
to take part in this very important
meeting to us this meeting is important
for many reasons to me as president of
the Republic of Poland this meeting is
important because Poland is the first
country after the corona virus pandemic
which has been invited to the meeting in
the White House to discuss the most
important matters concerning the future
concerning how the relations will look
between the United States and Poland in
terms of economy what those relations
will be like in the military sphere and
what those relations will be like in the
sphere of health protection all those
elements
which are of key importance today a very
big part of our discussions today with
mr. president and our collaborators were
dedicated to the I'm hearing utensils
clanging is it possible that the live
interpreter is like in the kitchen or
something is weird as concerns I fight
against the corona virus also in the
United States but first and foremost
we're also thinking about what measures
to take in the future but first and
foremost thank you so much mr. president
for your declaration that we are going
to cooperate but also our scientists are
going to cooperate and collaborate on
conducting research in concerning the
vaccine and therapy drug against corona
virus everything that will be conducive
to finding the corona virus so I do
believe thanks to this cooperation those
therapeutical medicines will be
available also for polls for my
competitor it's as soon as possible
thank you so much president for that
because all of us know very well how
high level of medical research is in the
state's investigation and the width of
cooperation on part of the United States
on part of the President of the United
States is of crucial importance to us so
thank you very much for that but ladies
and gentlemen we also discussed the
cooperation in the sphere of economy and
military let me first mention our
economic cooperation as the president
has just mentioned we are developing it
both in the sphere of energy in building
energy security today we can say that
the United States is cooperating in the
sphere of creating energy security not
only the early donor
energy security of Poland but also the
energy security of Central Europe the
president has just mentioned the three
seas initiative yes all the investments
that are being carried out in Poland
today the extension of the capacity of
LNG terminals Jam we're increasing its
capacity by 3.5 billion cubic meters we
are also plan to construct another
LNG terminal in the port of Gdansk all
of that is conducive to being able to
receive LNG gas and provide it
deliveries not only that person Poland
but also for the countries of Central
Europe the vast major how great would it
be if Trump pulled out his phone again
and tweeted still dependent on Russia
and creating a true alternative in other
words
diversification of supplies is of key
importance for their security thank you
mr. president for this cooperation I do
believe that we're going to further
develop it today we have got those
supplies guaranteed until 2023 by the
end of 2023 but I know that we are also
going to enter into further contracts in
this respect even more so that surely
our demand is going to increase but
ladies and gentlemen we also discussed
conventional energy and nuclear energy
cooperation in the nearest future in
America and the Republic of Poland and
thanks to this agreement will be able to
start designing the large design of
introducing conventional nuclear energy
for the production of electricity in
Poland the entities which will
participate in this project have already
been selected and the agreement very
advanced on the Polish side we've got
mr. piotrovsky who's in charge of those
negotiations right now the an
appropriate intergovernmental agreement
is about to be concluded and finalized
we can expect that to happen in the near
future ladies and gentlemen I also want
to mention the contribution of the
United States in to the three C's
initiative and first and foremost the
financial contribution today fund of the
three C's initiative about three minutes
ago Trump heard thank you and his
earpiece and nodded because he thought
it was rapping but it's it was your only
getting warmed up Thank You mr.
president for your activity and thank
you appreciate this Corporation which
takes place in Central Europe within the
framework of the European Union and the
goal of this cooperation is to develop
the extended infrastructure thank you
for noticing the possibility of
developing cooperation in the
transatlantic zone between the countries
of the European Union and the United
States and of course from my point of
view this cooperation with Poland
let's just all admit it we're speaking
about increasing military cooperation
between Poland and the United States it
is also of primary importance I have no
doubts whatsoever that this corporation
will lead to the strengthening of some
people seem to be joining the chat and
think this is actually the voice of the
president rather than the interpreter
and far most from my perspective it will
strengthen the security of Poland
and it will also land additional
financial credibility to Poland
investment credibility on part of
American investors when month ago a
global company Microsoft announced that
they're going to invest 1 billion
dollars in Poland at establishment
state-of-the-art
data center and today officially Google
company published the information that
is also going to invest in the center of
modern technologies in Poland including
IT technologies this is going to be an
even greater investment than investment
of Microsoft so mr. president I have no
doubts whatsoever that these American
investments and this additional
investment impulse that the American
companies are making right now
results from a very efficient policy
that we are conducting together and
which increases the sense of safety of
our citizens in Poland it also increases
the sense of safe investments in our
country thank you so much for that
because that means the creation of new
jobs in the state-of-the-art branch of
Industry I Trump listens for thank you
as a rap that's why he snapped turns
every time he hears it number of
excellent young IT experts also young T
young IT engineers and for sure we're
able to come to terms with these very
serious challenges also as far as than
intellectual capital is concerned I'm
sure that this investments are going to
be beneficial for the United States for
the US companies and also proponent
through creating jobs through acquiring
new experiences by young people in the
first place but young engineers I'm also
glad mr. president because as we said
before the agreements that we entered
into concerning increased US military
military prisons in Poland the
agreements we signed last year according
the first one the US forces going to be
increased by 1,000 troops in our country
and another so you guys think Trump will
take questions or that he's going to
bill without taking them what do people
think there's well be stationed in
Poland and the rotational basis but also
it's going to be heel to toe rotation
today we are entering another stage
namely there is a possibility of further
increase in American troops in our
country in recent days I also talked to
Secretary General of NATO
I talked to mr. yen Stoltenberg and we
agreed on one point especially as
Europeans we have no doubts whatsoever
that if any part of the US Armed Forces
which is the biggest armed forces in the
world was withdrawn from Europe that
would be very detrimental so you know I
believe it is deeply justified to ensure
that the US troops are left in Europe so
mr. president thank you so much for this
meeting today thank you so much
there's the snap turn on thank you for
accepting Poland during this meeting at
the White House the first country which
has been received after this long break
in international diplomacy thank you for
the words about our pride and heroism of
poles over history today Polish soldiers
stand arm in arm with US soldiers we are
tested allies together we spilled a
blood in Iraq and Afghanistan and we
stand ready always ready to implement
our Allied obligations I'm finding this
really inspirational I don't know about
you guys States
thanks to your policy mr. president is
demonstrating itself as a absolutely
loyal ally to us and thank you that we
can count on the United States also I'd
like to say that I'm grateful mr.
president you have been stressing
historical truths in such a decisive way
this is extremely important to us calls
fighting to Sebastian defending
historical truth also about the Second
World War about who started the war
about the course of the war is
incredibly important to us and Thank You
mr. president
that you are adopting this stance and
contributing so much to putting straight
the record straight it's important also
to us from the point of view of our
dignity the Second World War was a
period of great drama and trauma in the
period in the history of our nation we
lost 5 million citizens and that was a
tragedy to us will he mention because of
that spread this truth to present it as
it really was but it's also important to
speak about the heroism of polls
wherever they were fighting wherever
they were spilling there
blood army Nam with their allies at
Monte Cassino at Tobruk and at other
places all over the world both on the
eastern front and on the western front
all of that nothing you know
when foreign leaders come to the White
House it's common that there's an
interpreter these events are so common
but something about Trump as an element
of this just so bored clearly not
knowing what's going on
snap turning every time thank you comes
through it like something about this is
completely wacky towards the development
of our countries towards the development
of our societies towards the building of
a better more prosperous future both for
the United States for Poland and for
Europe thank you so much Wow well ask
one to me and one to the president and
that would be great
Steve Holland taking them oh my god the
mics we can't hear the reporter this is
horrible
Poland would you send them from Germany
and what sort of signal would that send
to Russia and for president Duda how do
you feel about this taking some troops
out of Germany to go to Poland and what
signal does that send to Russia thank
you well just to start as you know
Poland is as I've said many times Poland
is one of the few countries that are
fulfilling their obligations under me
you know in particular their monetary
obligations and the SS if we would send
some additional troops they're going to
pay for that they'll be paying for the
sending of additional troops and we'll
probably be moving them from Germany to
Poland we're going to be reducing
Germany versus potentially down to about
25,000 troops we actually had 52,000 but
we'll be yeah moving it we're gonna only
have 25,000 troops in Germany a very
small fraction of what they're supposed
to be paying they should be paying 2%
and they're paying a little bit more
than one percent depending on how you
calculate you could also calculate they
pay that they're paying less than 1% but
if you assume they're paying 1% that's a
tremendous delinquency let's use that
word delinquency so we're going to be
reducing our force
in Germany some will be coming home and
some will be going to other places but
Poland would be one of those other
places other places in Europe I think it
sends a very strong signal to Russia but
I think a stronger signal sent to Russia
is the fact that Germany is paying
Russia billions of dollars to purchase
energy from Russia and through the
pipeline and I'm saying what's that all
about
you're spending billions of dollars to
Russia then we're supposed to defend you
from Russia so I think it's a very bad I
think the people of Germany are very
unhappy about it I have many friends
from Germany and the people in Germany
are very unhappy about it they don't
like it but that's what they chose to do
so they're spending billions of dollars
to buy Russian energy and then we're
supposed to defend them from Russia so
that doesn't work too well but Poland
has been very very terrific in fact I
don't believe Poland is actually
accepting any of the energy from the
pipeline from Russia so that sends a
signal right there with all of that
being said we expect to get along with
Russia we expect to get along with
everybody we know but Germany has they
really owe a lot of money in NATO and
this has been going on for many years
when you add it all up you're probably
getting close to a trillion dollars and
that's not treating NATO fairly but it
really isn't treating the United States
fairly you know the United States is a
very is the major participant in you
know we pay more than anybody else by
far had for many many years so we defend
Europe but Europe also takes tremendous
advantage of the United States on trade
everybody just like you wouldn't believe
so we're trying to work that out and I
would imagine they'd like to wait till
after the election that you being the
president of the US and seeing us as the
constant perpetual victims in everything
or but that's the way it is okay thank
you very much please solve it Sarah
first of all
oh my god I respect very much both mr.
president Ellen Trump and the United
States of America
wonderful great state which today is the
largest military and economic superpower
in the world and I wouldn't dare say to
the President of the United States of
America where he should send his
soldiers because this is the decision
which is always taken by the United
States this is a very responsible
decision however I do not deny that I
requested mr. president that he would
not withdraw US forces from Europe
because the security of Europe is very
important to me from Europe as such I'm
talking about the United Europe for
which the American presence since the
end of the Second World War is a huge
security guarantee however if I'm asked
by anybody if I am ready that Poland
receives more US troops in our country
of course I am ready 2014 Russian
attacked Ukraine it annexed Crimea it
occupies organs and Donetsk before that
it had attacked Georgia 2014 was a year
of huge fears huge fears the Baltic
states and very big ones very constable
ones among the Polish society today the
presence of NATO troops and first and
formost of US troops in Poland
demonstrates that article 5 of the North
Atlantic Treaty is treated seriously and
it shows that if anyone wanted to attack
Poland it won't be a soft landing for
that entity it won't pay off for a
certain aggressor because the strongest
army of the world is present and they
would help polish soldiers to defend our
borders if such a case arises 100 years
ago we repelled Russians from war so in
a great battle in 1920 we defeated and
that was a great victory but we managed
to stop them only and very near to were
so at the outskirts of our capital city
we would never want to see the situation
repeated again that is why the alleged
presence is crucially important to us
today and it is a very important
security guarantee to us
very pleased that both within NATO as
well as in the United States and today
the president of the United States
understands the history of Europe and
the realities situation as it is
developing in Europe so today this
generates peace to my country it brings
security and thanks to that Russian
unfortunately very strong imperial
ambitions which have been revived over
the last tens of years I can say because
Georgia was attacked in 2008 thanks
those ambitions have been stopped for
the time being at least in this part of
the world and I have no doubt whatsoever
that this is also a huge merit of the
policy of the United States I'm grateful
for that just like all my compatriots
are when I add 2014 which the president
was talking of that was a year where
Russia had a good time with the United
States to the best of my knowledge
President Obama and sleepy Joe Biden
they were in power you knew they were
the ones that we're doing it this was
before us hasn't happened with us in a
war and whether I'll say that please go
ahead didn't you had to cancel your last
trip your last visit to Poland because
of the hurricane are you planning a new
visit to Poland in the near future and
the second question is on Kovac is there
a chance for Poland to participate in
the development and early access both to
the vaccine and to the therapeutics of
any presidential strands are not those a
boat just apes who I mean who knows if
we're even going to be the people who
first have the vaccine right I mean that
that's a question mark still as well yet
and fast access both the vaccine as well
as to concrete tracks against a virus
wing and we'd like to do it again as
soon as we can we have an election
happening in this country as you
probably have heard and so I probably
won't be able to do it until after the
election but assuming things go well the
answer is a very definite yes actually
as far as the joining with us on the
vaccines
and therapeutics by the way because the
therapeutics to me if you gave me a
choice right now probably
therapeutically maybe I'd I'd like that
even better but we're working very well
on both I think we're coming up with
some great answers I think you're gonna
have a big surprise a beautiful surprise
sooner than anybody would think but the
answer is yes we will be getting Poland
involved both in terms of helping but
also in terms of taking care of the
Polish people not at once we have the
vaccine but I think we're gonna have it
very soon okay thank you pioneered that
does a mister we got involved as a state
in the cooperation and also in
supporting allies bijna symbolic
dimension of the United States we have
here with us today
captain medical doctor from Poland I
want to say yes of course I'm working on
this obvious assumption that by taking
part in the research and also by being
in a certain sense co-creators of the
vaccines and therapeutics poles will be
able to count on these vaccines and
therapeutics to be available for the
poles as soon as possible so speaking
openly this is also the intention I have
in my cooperation with the United States
of America to make sure that these
vaccines are available to poles and to
other nations wherever they will be
applied as soon as possible thank you
very much
John please this afternoon the bill on
reform in the Senate failed to move
forward it may still see the light of
day at some point but at the moment it's
stalled in the Senate as well you have
an executive order that is coming out
later on this week regarding monuments
when you among people who deface or
damaged these monuments could you tell
us what you're planning to do in the
executive order and your reaction to
what happened in the Senate well the
Senate Republicans want very much to
pass a bill on police reform we have
total cooperation with many different
communities including the police
community yeah what the Republicans put
forward was
laughable dead-on-arrival joke they
agreed to that they would like to agree
to and there they would love to have it
agreed to formally the Democrats don't
want to do it because they want a week
in our police they want to take away
immunity they want to do other things
that you know about as well as anybody
in this in this beautiful in this
beautiful field that we said they want
to take away a lot of the strength from
our police and from law enforcement
generally and we can't live with that
we can't live with it this is a great
bill right strongly endorsed by as you
know Tim Scott who's terrific that's who
I go is a terrific man great senator
South Carolina and Mitch wants it just
so people don't don't miss this point
Tim Scott is a black Republican senator
so when Trump says Tim Scott endorsed it
Trump's saying I found a black guy to
bless going forward with this disastrous
bill this year the best and you hear
about certain places like Chicago and
you hear about what's going on in
Detroit and other other cities all
Democrat run every one of them's
Democrat run 20 out of 20 20 worst the
20 most dangerous are Democrat run yeah
we have the 20 richest cities also right
I mean it's like cities tend to be run
by Democrats urban areas tend to be more
democratic worse than Afghanistan
worse than Afghanistan and these are
cities within the United States Democrat
run radical left run you see what's
going on in Seattle you see what's going
on another place is Seattle of all
places who would even think that's
possible when I didn't do interpreting
this or the Polish president and he's
sitting there going what the hell is
this guy talking about and frankly they
want to defund largely at least largely
there are some that want to defund and
abolish release if you can believe that
and we're not letting that happen so if
nothing happens with it it's one of
those things we have different
philosophies they want open borders they
want sanctuary cities we nobody wants
open border huh as far as your number
your your second question I think that
we're gonna have a very strong executive
order but we
already have very strong we have the
monuments act already which which means
ten years in jail but I think we're
going to consolidate various things
we're going to come out with a very
strong executive order and I should have
that by the end of the week which is
fast approaching we're gonna have a very
very very powerful statement we've
arrested numerous people as you know for
what took place outside of Washington in
addition the FBI is investigating
hundreds of people throughout the
country for what they've done two
monuments statues and even buildings so
we have very strong laws already on the
books and we have a law that's ten years
it's ten years that's a long time to
have fun one night I think many of the
people that are knocking down these
statues don't even have any idea what
the statue is what it means who it is
when they knock down it's not clear a
lot of the people defending the statues
have any idea what they represent either
look at certain now they're looking at
Jesus Christ they're looking at George
Washington they're looking at Abraham
Lincoln Thomas Jefferson not gonna
happen not gonna happen not as long as
I'm here as far as Democrats are
concerned I think they could care less
whether or not it happens Carole and I
think the American people get it so
we're gonna have a very strong executive
order and it'll happen very quickly
before the end of the week the sirens
are a nice touch we have an election
coming up in November you have an
election coming up on Sunday some of
your critics who are politicians here in
the United States have criticized this
visit to the White House saying it is
tantamount to election interference
because it shows a very close
relationship between the United States
and Poland at a time when you really
need it what do you say to those critics
said mr. president feel free to weigh in
if you want to
some of Nippon yeah said they're ciske
sir first of all like me let me also
follow up on the question that you asked
to President Donald Trump I would like
to thank you mr. president because among
others not a long time ago the monument
to general that those Costa Rica was
devastated there was the national hero
of Poland but also the national hero of
the United States it was fighting for
the independence of the United States
had great merits and he was also the
commander of a Polish uprising and where
he was fighting for the independence of
Poland he severed heavy wooden these are
not exactly the guys I would go to if I
want to learn the history of civil
rights in Poland in the United States
and was devastated recently and thank
you so much that it has been renewed so
fast and that's that was that made it
possible for me to lay flowers at that
Monument and pay tribute to the great
soldier and a great commander thank you
for that that was outrageous for a big
number of Polish people back in Poland
all of them probably and for many many
Polish people living here also in the
United States Polish organizations here
in the United States asked me and told
me that they would renew that monument I
know that it has already been renewed by
the United States no assistance was
needed so I'm very grateful for that
that here the monument to those
questions cost tens near the White House
and he looks as he should look odd which
he has reserved for Daenerys delayed for
the United States and for polenta thank
you very much for that mr. president and
answering a question two months ago
at the very beginning of the pandemic of
coronavirus we had lend a conversation
with president ram the pandemic
disrupted the plans of our cooperation
which we had and back then we made an
arrangement with mr. president that we
would meet as soon as it would be
possible and this has been implemented
and the fact that this arrangement has
being put into force is demonstrated by
the visit today I'm very grateful to mr.
president for inviting me here today and
together with mr. president we are
implementing our presidential duties the
president is always in charge of his
national interests and this is the task
of the president when the president is
acting in the international sphere this
is my sensor net but I also know that
also it is a very strong belief a
president ultram the president is
supposed to realize the interest of
their country so mr. president Trump is
realizing the interest of his own
country and I'm realizing the interest
of Poland so we are looking for a
win-win situation where both parties are
the winners where both parties are able
to implement their interests as part of
the cooperation which we are
implementing this is the way we act and
in this moment we are acting on a
national level in the state level we are
just fulfilling our obligations and
duties as presidents of our countries as
those who are representing our nations
and who want our societies to have as
good lives as possible thank you very
much Ben very well in Poland he's doing
a terrific job the people of Poland
think the world of him and by the way
this is Duda with a terrific woman
terrific woman who we've gotten to know
also through our various travels and
meetings but they think the world of him
and I don't think he needs my help I'm
honored that this is a day that's I
guess just before your election I'm
honored but the audio that he will do
very well with or without us he's going
to have a great success and Poland is
going to continue on they're doing
incredibly well as a country okay please
best regards to polish television good
morning Palestine Czech polish
television I want to ask about timing of
that visit president MJ Duda is the
first president the first international
guests in the White House since the
lockdown and today there was a big
military parade in Moscow can we combine
those two facts okay is it kind of proof
that America the Poland is an important
partner for America can we treat it that
we can rely on America in Poland thank
you
well I think you can and we also are
working with Russia right now on an arms
treaty which is a very big thing oh my
good nuclear arms specifically but we're
working very much and I think I could
say what are we doing very well on that
we're two countries that want to see it
happen and we're working on other things
with Russia we have a very good
relationship we have our ambassador over
there right now he'll be attending
certain festivities and that's a good
thing and I think that's frankly a good
thing for Poland also likewise we're
going to be having very important
dignitaries at at your parade you're
gonna be having a very big event soon
and we're gonna be I guess in August and
right we're gonna have people
representing the United States at a very
high level and that's very important to
us also okay sir I have this feeling in
sense that I'm conducting negotiations
in Polish matters here in very
experienced and a very tough politician
tough player I can say that is President
Donald Trump who is attending strongly
and looking to the interest of his
country and his citizens what I'm doing
here is I'm representing pillaging the
street here and I'm not parading in
Moscow that is all thank you very much
thank you all very much
we will see you soon thank you thank you
very much
and desiring
[Applause]
[Music]
what can we what can we even say my
friends what can we even say
unbelievable
alright that's gonna do it for me we are
off the next couple of days so I will
likely next talk to everybody on Monday
Monday Monday remember if you're
watching on Twitch just give us that
free follow it costs nothing if you're
watching on YouTube hit that subscribe
button give us a like on Facebook follow
me on Twitter
I'll be back with everybody very very
soon trust me on that one
you